[Aplausos]
todos tenemos un modelo ser consciente o
inconscientemente todos nosotros tomamos
una persona de nuestra realidad para
convertir en nuestro referente e
inspirarnos por sus acciones
ahora con el desarrollo tecnológico y
los medios de comunicación nuestra
realidad se expandió pues ahora podemos
conocer la vida de personas que tal vez
no están cerca de nosotros físicamente y
está hecho que podamos enterarnos de
nuevas ideologías y culturas que pueden
afectar como pensamos y muchas veces
hasta en cómo estamos también así como
se presenta en la teoría se hace del
aprendizaje de albert bandura donde se
dice que para que una persona imite a
otra modelo a otra ésta debe prestar
atención motivarse y retener toda la
información que le sirva para reproducir
en su conducta
de todas las personas que nos rodean así
sea en la vida real o en las redes
sociales hay muy pocas que tomamos como
referentes quiénes son esas personas
desafortunadamente ahora pensamos que
debemos seguir a gente exitosa por su
dinero y fama sin necesariamente tomar
en cuenta sus acciones en sí
supongo que saben algo sobre la mayoría
de personas que están en esta foto
estas celebridades son las que muchos
jóvenes incluyendo nos todos como
modelos a seguir sin embargo no todos
valen la pena imitar por ejemplo emma
watson y michelle obama siempre han
apreciado y respetado a las personas que
les rodean sin tomar en cuenta su nivel
de fama y tienen sus metas y objetivos
de vida bien definidos por lo que
podrían ser considerados adecuados
modelos a seguir por el contrario otras
celebridades han actuado de manera
negativa ante ciertos asuntos lo que les
impide ser un referente adecuado para
personas que están creciendo y
desarrollando su personalidad en mi caso
yo hace dos años tenía como modelo a
seguir a un genio del beso y yo por mi
lado tenía de modelo seguir a rihanna
ambas celebridades estarían en un punto
medio porque nosotros les admiramos por
su personalidad pero no por sus
objetivos de vida porque no llevan
acordes a los nuestros es decir yo no
seguía eugenio derbez porque yo quería
estudiar actuación y yo tampoco se
llamaría no porque quería cantar solo le
seguíamos por sus maneras de actuar
pero bueno todos tus pensamientos sobre
nuestros modelos a seguir cambiaron el
momento en el que nos dimos cuenta que
estábamos siendo un modelo a seguir esto
comenzó en el diciembre 2017 cuando las
dos decidimos entrar en un proyecto del
colegio en el cual brindamos clases de
inglés a niños de bajos recursos en
nuestro sector este primer año primer
periodo lectivo
trabajamos con siete niños de quinto de
básica aproximadamente de ocho y nueve
años que nos hicieron enamorarnos
completamente de este proyecto bueno
para hacerles sinceras en un inicio
solamente hacíamos lo que se supone que
debe hacer y nada más porque pensamos
que ellos nunca aprenderían o que tal
vez ni siquiera les interesaba pero esto
con el pase con el paso de las clases
cambió pues si les interesaba mucho
entonces comenzamos a buscar formas más
divertidas y creativas haciendo que
ellos canten y bailen o que actúen
porque pensamos que debíamos poner el
mismo esfuerzo que ellos ponen en la
clase y así fue como como nuestro camino
a darnos cuenta que éramos referentes
comenzó
nos dimos cuenta de esto porque al
principio de este periodo lectivo había
una niña que era súper tímida no le
gustaba aprender no no tenía la
intención de aprender
pero bueno todo esto cambio al final de
ese mismo periodo lectivo
porque ella comenzó a tomar atención a
nuestras conductas de las clases y
mediante sus acciones nos dio a entender
que ahora sí le interesa aprender y que
se abra la posibilidad de compartir con
sus amigos eso a no ser que nos den
orgullos ya muchísimo porque convenció
comenzó a retener comportamientos
nuestros ya reproducirlos gracias a la
ayuda ya la confianza que le dimos
asimismo hubo un pequeño que una clase
se puesto a llorar pues sus amigos se
comenzaron a burlar de él por suerte él
vino hacia nosotras y nos contó cuáles
eran las verdaderas razones por las que
se sentía tan mal
aquí fue con nosotros decidimos darle
consejos que venían desde nuestra
experiencia y así es emotivo
reproducirlos a su vida hacia lo saber
que él confiaba en nosotras y que no se
estaba tomando como referentes para
problemas que anteriormente había tenido
y de esta manera toda su gratitud es la
nuestra cada vez que se despedía de
nosotras cuando lo hacía con una gran
sonrisa y un abrazo al ver que tuvimos
un gran impacto en estos niños decidimos
regresar al proyecto este periodo
lectivo donde nos encontramos con muchas
más sorpresas que la anterior teníamos
un grupo más grande y dos de ellos eran
del grupo pasado
bueno algunas experiencias fueron
similares como los de un niño que igual
al principio era super tímido pero ahora
se expresa con muchísima libertad y con
una pasión que nunca habíamos visto
antes y algo que nos sorprendió mucho ya
mí en lo personal me llenó el corazón
fue cuando mi cumpleaños
todos ellos organizaron para cantar me
acompañó es feliz en inglés y uno de
ellos hasta me regaló un dibujo de su
colección retomando así la teoría
planteada donde se dice que la
motivación no se lo da del modelo a las
otras personas sino también en dirección
contraria y así todas estas experiencias
nos hicieron dar cuenta que ya formamos
parte de su realidad y que estábamos
influyendo en estos niños y por esta
misma razón debemos intentar ser nuestra
mejor versión y aquí fue cuando
finalmente lo entendimos nuestros modelo
de seguir ha afectado nuestra forma de
ser que era la misma con la que nos
presentábamos a los niños entonces ellos
estaban siendo afectados indirectamente
desde dos celebridades así como la
cabeza
entonces si es que rihanna y eugenio
derbez eran nuestros modelos hasta y
respectivamente y nosotros éramos
modelos a seguir de los niños
por consiguiente riendo y el gen o
berbés también sería el modelo a seguir
de los niños esto significa que todas
las acciones que nosotros invitamos de
estas dos personas los niños también las
tienen pero indirectamente y aquí fue
cuando nos preguntamos si es que
realmente vale la pena que estas dos
personas sean nuestros modelos a seguir
pues como se podrían imaginar no no
valía la pena porque a pesar de que
nosotros le admirábamos de estas
personas por características específicas
cuando les comenzaron a prestar atención
todo el tiempo que teníamos conductas
que quizá nosotros no queríamos
reproducir pero lo hacíamos
inconscientemente entonces dejamos de
lado estas celebridades y comenzamos a
buscar a gente que puede aportar mucho
más en nuestras vidas ya sea teniendo
metas similares o beneficiando de alguna
manera la sociedad en mi caso yo ahora
tengo como uno de mis modelos a seguir a
mi prima porque
el estudio diseño gráfico se fue
especializando en barcelona y la
apasiona muchísimo lo que hace y bueno
yo aparte de querer seguir la misma
carrera universitaria quisiera llegar a
tener el mismo nivel de éxito que él
yo por mi parte tengo de modelo a
seguir'
una de mis tías en segundo grado porque
a pesar de que a lo largo de su vida a
su familia le daba todo lo que ya quería
y lo consentían mucho ella decidió irse
a otro país para ser completamente
independiente y eso es lo que yo quiera
ir a otro lugar vale en el post mí misma
y saber que todas las cosas que yo tenga
hayan sido fruto de mi expuesto
dedicación como pudieron ver nosotros
ahora tenemos como modelos a gente que
está más cerca de nuestra realidad y que
ha hecho cosas que nosotros quisiéramos
hacer y ahora que ya tenemos eso claro
comenzamos a transmitirle eso no sólo a
los niños sino también a las personas
que se encuentran cerca de nosotros y es
por esto que tener un modelo a seguir
que valga la pena es tan importante y no
sólo por nosotras y nuestro
desarrollo de la personalidad sino
también por todas las personas que
amamos a la final nunca sabremos es que
12 o algunas de ellas no se están
tomando como referentes para marcar sus
acciones y sin embargo sería mucho mejor
intentar aportar positivamente
y volvernos un obstáculo en el
crecimiento de alguien que tanto
queremos
entonces ustedes a quién elegirían como
su modelo a seguir gracias
[Aplausos]